thanks for coming out to to hear will
and Dave talk today they've got a kind
of a cool talk ahead for you it'll touch
a little bit on beyond Earth and beyond
Earth rising tide but that when they
pitch this talk to us at fraxinus they
said we kind of want to give you some
insight into how a sieve game gets men
and we were like that sounds cool and
they're like we think the people at
fracks con will really like it we were
like we also agree with this so I'll let
them come up ladies and gentlemen will
miller and Dave McDonough kohli
designers of sid meier's civilization
beyond Earth okay I'm will this is Dave
we're lead designers to sid meier's
civilization beyond Earth and rising
tide the new expansion and the topic of
our talk here today who civ is it anyway
this is going to be an interesting
experiment and perhaps an unmitigated
disaster it'll be funny man but it'll be
funny so you guys will have a good time
regardless but as Pete said we wanted to
give you kind of a behind-the-scenes
look at what our process is for
designing a new sieve Geng so we're
going to do that on stage right now
we're going to design a new sieve Geng
around a new idea and we're gonna do
this with your help and some the help of
some special guests Brett's right so we
thought what would save game can we
design we just did science fiction in
the future what else will where we go
next fantasy and what we do let's go the
other way totally so we're gonna die in
it I said game about prehistory what
happened in the stone age is the time of
legends the myths everything happens
before agriculture so like a sieve game
before regular shift game right so for
in order to do that we got to confront
the basic question the question that
confronted us when we made beyond Earth
which was what really makes it sip what
is the thing that this game has that it
seemed to have had for the past 24 years
but other for X Games don't quite have
the no other game the Francis made quite
has what is it that that is at the heart
of that sieve magic what is possessive
identity so
for us like it's sort of by examining
what's the difference between a sieve
game another forex game like it's got
all the exes for sure but there's
there's an interesting blend of how how
to treat it like how it treats the map
how it treats those short in the
long-term decision making what kind of
questions it puts to the players and how
willing it is really to like make you
think hard about who you are and what
you want to do and like who those people
on the other side of the map are and
what they're trying to do how you're
going to use this world or how you're
going to exploit it or how you're going
to save it and stuff like that so right
and I think at the heart of the city
identity is the myth of civilization so
lots of praxis games use myth as the
underpinning for the games fiction and
we do this because you bring the myth as
a player you bring the myth to the game
so if you think about our classic game
civilization is is sort of an elementary
school understanding of history that's
the myth that you bring to that game or
sid meier's pirates the idea of a pirate
we don't have to explain that to you so
in a game like sieve prehistory what are
we going to call this game Dave dawn of
civ yeah doc doc the abbreviations are
important the forums we use them doc all
right so in dawn of civ I kind of see
two variations of this is a clan of the
cave bear on one hand and like conan on
the other hand like where do we fall in
this electrolyte going I like going into
like so that's that's a great question
like um his like classic sieve is as we
like to say the elementary school
textbook version of history the very
layman's knowledge see if likes to use
the phrase do your history research
after you make the game and we take that
very seriously we deliberately
approached our games with a very stupid
perspective in order to make them as a
prote no we um we want the game to be to
reinforce the things that everybody
already knows about and already thinks
are cool because that's why you think
the game is cool like the game never
makes you feel dumb or makes you feel
like you needed to learn more in order
to appreciate it so when we're talking
about like Stone Age times what people
tend to think of like cavemen and
mammoths and like this huge pristine
world full of like six-foot dragonflies
and crazy things and
I I really like the idea that the games
got a little bit of the mystical in it
and it's got a little bit of a myth like
part of what makes prehistory
fascinating is because before we really
appreciated why all of these things
happen like we thought there was thunder
because I'll Thunder God made it not
because we understand physics so I
really think that that ought to be in
the game we should have prehistory
should be a little bit of the little bit
of a myth and legend and a little bit of
the reality all right so this is where
you guys come into play this is Pete
over here with the mic he's going to be
walking around what what are other
aspects of this myth that you would put
in a civilization games everybody out
there that's got a winner okay all right
you can't have cities can you well we're
gonna get to that so we'll get to we'll
get to growth of cities creation of fire
yeah you shove a higher victory
condition done Oh actually I was gonna
say fire too but ok stone terminus all
right ok thank you I want to be able to
hunt and kill a woolly mammoth all right
yes woolly mammoth I'm gonna start
wearing the step down very poor very
poor horses horses or the domestication
thereof got one up here uh dealing with
the elements elements ok so that kind of
that kind of suggests dr. grades a
mammoth super high I want to play this
game iris loss for expansion expansion
right
right alright so so these are some
kernels we can we could roll with these
will bring them in as we go so let's
start talking about they're like the
pillars like go through some of those
X's or the sin of the exes and say like
these are things that are in every sieve
game that are usually a huge part of the
game and the designers talk a lot about
that players talk a lot about that are
really important if and when they change
from cipa SID so we're gonna start with
exploration and I think before we get
into this it's important to for us to
say that like when we design sieve games
we don't generally think about the exes
all right we think about the fantasy
what is it that the player does and why
do they do it and how do we make
mechanics to facilitate that and that
like I think for X the idea of a Forex
game was imposed on what civilization
was after the fact I don't know if I
mean you can ask him he's sitting up
here I don't know Sid came up the ex's
first and then made the game but it's
all about the fantasy for us so I think
he's thinking those terms are more like
the pillars right right so to help us
out with exploration will call to the
stage Jake Salomon lead designer on
ExComm Jake ranks up here right here
please so set hut hut Mike got a hot
like here all right so Jake people may
not know this about you Jake but you
spent a lot of time on civ rev I did I
did it I spent a lot of time on civ rev
yes I good game I lukewarm um I look I
also worked on Sid i started my I
started the company on civ 3 and then
also worked on sit for so you got more
than enough South cred to earn that
chair um sure yeah that wasn't a
question yes yes then of course I do yes
so when we say exploration in civ that's
often like citizen game with votes it's
the game with it's the planes game right
okay right okay yeah what do you think
about when you think about explorations
um yeah exploration I think that's kind
of the heart for me it's probably my
favorite pillar because there's two
sides to it I think that as a player
there's something very very powerful
both automatically mechanically about
pushing back the darkness right i mean
it is that sense of possible
that all of the fog of war represents
that as a player being able to push that
back is very exciting and never liked
that part never ever ever get sold them
at how many thousands of games of SIDS
you play and then I think the other
aspect that is that once you push back
the darkness it allows you to have both
short-term decision-making so as a
player like which direction am I going
and then as you reveal something like
I'm gonna follow this I'm gonna dig into
this natural feature and then over a
short period of time you start building
a medium and then long-term strategy
when you're like oh man I got to build
my next city here oh man I'm up against
this sieve over here and so the
exploration part it's very fun and
exciting and then it also is the
foundation for the player and the most
part to me and strategy games is
formulating a strategy and then you get
kicked off in your strategy that you
form and you develop a new one but being
able to form that strategy comes out of
exploration being able to say okay
here's the lay of the land this time
okay I know what I'm gonna do I'm build
sitting here then i might go here and
then and got to be careful about this
later over here so clicks Porsche is
really the point of which a sieve game
sets the stage yeah it says like here's
the world you're in look how beautiful
and incredible it is also look how
dangerous it is yep and it's where you
decide who you are in the game and what
kind of game you're gonna play yeah yeah
that's where you set your initial
thoughts which invariably at least for
me turn out to be wrong but you have
these initial thoughts of luck I know
exactly how this is gonna go so yeah I
guess in a in the context of a
prehistory game that darkness you
mentioned is a very literal darkness
right yeah if people were you know
pushing back the darkness with fire and
that's why the prehistory could be very
exciting with exploration because you
know you'd have yeah I mean I think that
then you you know you can have like big
hump two things coming out of the fog or
you know you see like a giant you know
dragons back or something cuz again this
concept of there be dragons you know
prehistory game there could actually be
dragons um so so like in addition to
their just being a lot of space that you
haven't seen did you have to explore
what makes exploration hard like what's
what's the obstacle there that we could
put into prehistory said oh I suck
hose yeah i think that prehistory i
suppose the fact is that somebody could
lose themselves if they wander off too
far right and so i guess that kind of
feeds in the idea of building up this
even this concept of civilization like a
prehistory game i think you're you can't
just come into with this idea of
civilization but perhaps you know you
could put limits on the extent that you
explore would not be fun but i think
that having that having some sort of
choice mechanic in there i think would
be pretty interesting so maybe you could
make it that you explore better and a
certain pattern or around certain things
or once you establish the mythology of a
certain area maybe you can explore
faster in that area okay yeah it's
interesting you say that the sort of you
get lost idea it almost seems to suggest
like what what would it do to the game
if we took away the map the mini-map I
mean like if you if usually had to track
your progress through the world by
putting down markers or watching your
footsteps even or something like that
you think that kind of thing goes too
far would it be annoying to the player
just does it add something to the home
it'd be interesting to take something
like that out of a sieve game you know
how would I feel I think that if you
push it as a mechanic that could
potentially work um yeah I'm sitting
there thinking like man yeah you could
definitely when you're exploring you
could have different scales obviously
yes the producers are immediately going
like what but if you had different
scales of the games were like in the
exploration phase like you're only
you're playing a minute you like the
game you're playing for the first hour
is one tile you know it's like a single
tile and then it takes you you know the
next half of the game moves to like a
circle of tiles and then immediately
you're like okay now we've uncovered
some tech or built some civilization
that allows us to range further and so
for me as a player I would love that
because pushing back the darkness is
probably my favorite thing so if you had
two scales to the game where okay i have
this map and you can sell the mini-map
but it's only really for in later stage
of the game it's one tile you know and
so the game sort of scales up as you
play along so good back in the box
feature scaling yeah so you scale from
the single campsite in the sea of
darkness to a little family group to
write to civilization the tribe yeah
wait a minute I want this game idea now
I'm just gonna stay for the record in
the internet that no point should anyone
assume that we'll ever make a product
even remotely like this disavow any any
future effort I'm not getting excited
now what about scaling civilization okay
yes what about that like you were
talking about the uncertainty and you
know seeing this hump that looks like a
dragon right one of the cool things
about expiration me is that like you go
play something you said you think you
know it's there when you'll eat while
you're gone it changes you have to come
back sure so what if we played on that a
little bit the world around you that you
aren't actively looking at is kind of
shifting in the seas like you're totally
understand it until you've got it nailed
down yeah so you can have these like big
creatures or continents and things move
in a way that is sort of extraordinary
the gnosis if game is done that you you
have to have active site on or you have
to like to settle before it'll kind of
stick that's interesting so yeah so as
the so you get this again that would
give you a sort of sense of scaling
exploration where again that you still I
think would be great because or that
allow you to do I guess is to have more
exploration throughout the game where it
never gets kind of old until a certain
point borders are set or you know enough
or you have a certain tank I think
that'd be awesome that's kind of one of
the interesting problems with civ late
game or mid game is once you've once you
too kind of explored the whole map the
map becomes much less interesting you
don't have the exploration to kind of
pull you through and to have the
landscape sort of shift underneath you
almost if you're not careful or if you
don't have site would be pretty would be
pretty cool I think it also reinforces a
sort of power relationship like instead
of you take over the world um because
you're human kind and you have that
power but impressive you're pretty weak
relative to the world the world is
pretty big impressive dangerous place
there's actually something we thought a
lot about on beyond Earth but you wanted
the alien planet to be dangerous and you
don't belong there right you got to work
hard to belong there so maybe like sort
of a similar are could be going on in
this game like by the time we've got
figured out firing agriculture and
writing yeah we can be ready to take
over the world but before that the world
could like squish us any concern so like
this is a very real way of representing
that to have the world be this almost
living thing like the land is a living
thing that is like got its own agenda
and your kind of writing it and then you
zoom out and you realize you were only a
small tribe of Barbie
turns in a game of civ you know and if
somebody comes in with tanks and just
crush you that's how it ends all right
well on that note I think well think I
should does it end on that one thanks
very much because I guy leaves get him a
jig Solomon all right moving on okay
step two step two how does our
civilization grow so growth is I guess
the expand X and the exploit X kind of
rolla bill and the build soil roads on
everything right growth is a pretty big
topic but how does the idea of growth
change when somebody suggested on the
audience when we don't have a city
anymore or when our cities are movable
or before we developed any kind of
architecture right before we developed
any kind of architecture so I guess the
first thing we should talk about our are
what are the constraints to growth so
we'll get Pete back in the audience here
where is you think about in prehistory
what were the constraints to growth
various families coming together instead
of just a single family group oh so a
lot much more intimate focus where
you're like at the personal tribe level
but back then there were no maps so like
you were saying about the map all the
darkness could creep back uh that you
know as you lose sight of things you
lose what you had There yeah okay all
right that sounds good I was gonna say
the change of the seasons would
definitely affect on what pops up as
resources on the map so that suggests a
different time scale talk about that in
a minute one turnin when the civ game is
a year we couldn't have to change that I
would think like fear and understanding
of the world could be a potential
mechanic fear is a mechanic okay i would
say migratory herds or food sources or
resources that move around you would
have to follow that's already i think
let's call it there that's a good set so
I like that the idea of those like
animals like I like that the world is
full of big living things that are scary
and dangerous but eventually you're
going to learn how to hunt them and then
they're going to be food
right that's a good story so I'm
Commandments we've made us at the top of
our list already so we another key
factor in growth in in prehistory was
the invention of agriculture so if you
think about what agriculture is
represented as an civilization game it's
building improvements on things or it's
like it's mastering the land so we push
back the darkness now we master the land
what are the ways in which prehistory
society would do this like what would be
what would take the place of
improvements or of a worker or you know
that part of the game I think to me in
my mind it sounds like what i would call
like tradition or ritual like if you're
if you're a if you're a nomadic saving
your chase and the Bison around you
don't need to improve things but you
develop this mythology this ritual
around the Bison and you and your
symbiotic relationship and you know the
landscape you travel every season your
children are raised to understand the
cycle they know they like revere the
Bison and so on so what if it was like
that like you have landscape that's like
wild and as you move around if you
traverse sort of common paths or if you
follow a certain species of creature
those become tame or safe for your sip
and you were like you can dwell there
you can grow up there it's not so you
can you can move you don't have to
settle down in the sense that you have
to build on a single tile but you're
sort of like kind of sweeping the ground
and scrubbing it in a way in order to
make a safe ground and not dangerous
ground and that kind of dovetails with
the with cities that can or i guess i
guess not cities really it's your tribe
right yeah you have a tribe that it's
moving to follow the elements i think
that having elements not be a fixed
entity on the map or at least in the
beginning of the game you follow the
caribou you follow the you know the
bison all right and also back that's
gonna I think work interestingly into
the combat system too I guess we'll talk
a little bit about that later but if you
have to kill the thing you eat that's
food right you hunt and you gather
gathering is a great impetus for
exploration hunting is a great emphasis
for combat those could drive your group
food is sort of the driver for growth in
instead of currently the more you eat
the more population you get bigger city
kids so that could be a much more active
participation you know our active thing
you do in the game you make the land
safe
you hunt for food your civilization
groves just occur to me that nobody
might be able to read this except for us
can anybody read this doesn't matter it
well is for our own reference later
don't worry about alright so so you you
have lead like this wilderness that's
shifting under around you and wherever
you send your tribe the more the place
that you go those are places you're
making safe or known and animals are
like units in themselves and they sweep
around and you can hunt and kill them
for your food the more you do that the
more you understand them and you can do
it better or you can predict their
movements and so on what's the goal here
the goal is ultimately to get to the
point of the city right like yeah we're
sort of we're trying to arrive at the
beat at the first turn of regular Sid
which is first city right so that is
agriculture so maybe along the way you
are developing agriculture you can leave
camps or you can be family groups in
certain places that are eventually going
to settle down and dwell right maybe at
like the intersection of of migratory
patterns like the Okavango or Fertile
Crescent you know we're going to park
here because animals come by all the
time I'm gonna suck up food from them
until we figure out how we have to not
need them anymore if you're going to do
agriculture so you know this questions
coming Dave Sid you know it's coming too
you've made this distinction between
safe and unsafe what is the UI look like
for this so you I is it is sort of the
way the game works and even at this
early stage we're already thinking about
how we will interact with the game how
we what what the handles are how it's
going to look and we have already got
some pretty complex state on the map and
sib currently so we've got black fog
gray fog white fog we're going to need
to add more information to the map to
represent this safe unsafe idea how do
we do that well I mean the first thing I
see is actually a literal art style
difference like the wild wild land looks
wild like the shapes are jagged and
maybe they're shader is different there
like dark and swirly and the animals in
them look kind of evil and then tame
land is likes if it looks green and
fertile and pleasant and the okay Andrew
we've got budget for two art styles
right yeah okay
think of it as one art style look at two
modes no no done next week so all right
so so this is our growth really we're
what we're growing is not so much our
improvement infrastructure but our
ability to exist safely really the tribe
is growing we're kind of like we're
scrubbing land in to safeland we're
learning the patterns of them of the
moving animals and the like the nature
of the plants or whatever with a view to
eventually domesticate / agriculture
them sounds good alright movin on movin
on up next our fightin fightin combat to
help us with combat we're gonna call up
tennis shirt dennis is the franchise
producer for civ he was the producer on
civ 5 and others things beyond her more
a greater expert in civilization there
may not be short of Sid himself right
and just for reference all of these
ideas are property of 4 axis games you
will not go in the credits just our nose
so Dennis talk to us a little bit about
your your experience with civilization
in the context of of combat in units so
these are the pieces you have on the
board there we put a lot of effort into
their art what is their main function in
the game well at least from my
experience I'm not a game designer this
this all comes down to adding a level of
stress to the game you've got this
situation where you're exploring and
you're expanding and exploiting and
there's nothing really to check that
except maybe other decisions that the
eye is making the order in which they
might be researching or building things
but there's nothing to stop you from
just going to town and doing exactly
what you want when you want it where you
want it and combat provides that wild
card of sorts there are the things that
you can't necessarily plan for the
barbarians that show up on your doorstep
and start burning down your field Zerbe
AI player that's mad at you for selling
to close it suddenly puts together a a
rather large army and goes rampaging
across takes al burns down your science
research city it's it's that kind of
pressure that without that I don't think
it's as compelling a game I normally
play a very builder or in a game that's
high place if I always my favorite one
is just going for the cultural victory
at with brave new world when introducing
the great works that's how I like to
play
I never maintained like these huge
standing armies but I always have to
maintain just enough because things will
happen and you got to kind of prepare
for that it takes you out of your
comfort zone in terms of doing exactly
what you want to do it because the real
world is is full of surprises and that's
where that's where this really shines
it's really good insight my favorite way
to play is to conquer the person is
going for the culture victory that's
good right right so thinking about that
were speed thinking about that um
comment combat what are the things you
fight what a caveman and how is he
waiting like work like we're imagining
where we've got a smaller tribe with
maybe more individuals rather than like
big armies I was thinking more along
lines of to have a soldier me you know
developed you would have them send out
to the wild to compete you know for our
trophy to bring back so that they could
be a soldier in interesting so more
elaborating other things coming out of
combat to make the soldier better that's
good as interesting like XP and veteran
see is really big deal yeah have another
sub species of humans so that's that's
the clan of the cave bear right you got
the Neanderthals and the in the Homo
sapiens and they're sort of they have
different attributes and are vying for
control of the land that's a good that's
a good option those putting on my
producer head for a moment i'm sure they
would say players would say i want to be
able to play as in Neanderthals and that
means for alternative play modes vicious
animals and indigenous wildlife that's
not exactly friendly like maybe um
vicious mammoth dinosaurs mammoth
mammoth off our list right mammoth so so
just just to pause an elaborate on that
for a second one of the other functions
of combat that that is kind of
interesting is that it provides an early
game kind of attaboy almost like the
first first barbarians you encounter you
sort of roll over and it feels awesome
so maybe those may be conquering the
wild animals or not maybe at the
mammoths but you know the pack of wolves
or whatever is sort of that serves that
same function mythic quests and you know
spirit journeys for warriors things like
oh I like listed we were bracing a
little bit of a legendary this game
could go for like a big beast ah oh
won't get to technology later a little
more toward the late game cuz these
early cultures actually didn't lose a
lot of people to battles because you
couldn't survive there was a lot of
intimidation you could have a mystical
power over someone else you can use fire
they don't have fire so they back down
or you win and then you intermarry and
take over their tribe so we don't have a
diploma see slide in here I think that
sounds like a good I think that's enough
people enough to move on for now yeah so
um so we've already established that the
world is a dangerous place right yeah so
there's I think we're gonna do that
versus the wild beasts things really
well like I actually really like the
idea that they're the same as the ones
you need to eat and like right there
like you know those mammoths or the you
know to hell the Bison could totally
kill your guys early game until you
figure out the right tools at the right
hunting techniques and then they like
the tables turn and they become food
sources I think we're always looking for
opportunities to overlap systems like
this we good interplay we overlap combat
with cult or combat with growth because
you killed the food that you eat right
on that's a that's a good synergy that's
an interesting uh you mentioned talk
about the tech tree a little later but
it's also brings something into play
when you're talking about just
prehistory what that might look like and
that would be a fun exploration in terms
of even just your units I mean if we're
going from nothing at all or punching to
clubs and that's the space of time that
we have or maybe we go to the spear what
does everything in between look like are
you going from punching and the next
thing you research is rock in hand
there's a lot of opportunities good to
see the icon now yeah you're right
before you ever have a chance to get to
horseback riding or you're riding around
on cows or bison or something like that
way who's running a cow it would be
about a second could be very cool pigs
right small people denson size your
tribe there's always a lot of
opportunities for something like that I
still think that eventually you have to
ride around on a dinosaur at some point
but maybe that could be a mod I've
always wanted to see it on the civ game
it sounds like it i know that would
split the fan community right down the
middle with half that not so we think
it's the worst idea in the world the
other half this like yes we need more
GDRs yeah those are the question that
constantly faces safe designers is that
you can't please everybody and most of
the time you're not going to please
anybody right so you improve your
military in two different ways in civ
you sort of improve them at the high
level a whole class of military gets
better through tech progression but also
the individual units get better through
promotion and I think it would be
needing this game to sort of flip the
emphasis so like an ex calm you become
very
hatch to your soldiers because you have
fewer of them and there they have more
personality until they get killed then
you're still attached to but then you're
still attached to the surface emotional
connection so maybe if we're dealing
with a tribe of people as opposed to
armies of people we could swap those
around what do you think I don't know it
seems like if we're dealing down the
tribal level that you might end up
getting a little too uh too attached to
them especially afternoon this is this
is George my son the caveman and he's
going off to battle and he's going to
die eventually but you have towards the
second enjoy the third it's an
interesting question of storage or
georgas when you're when you're
producing in a typical civ game when
you're starting at the dawn of actual
civilization you can create armies and
armies and armies and send them forth
and if we're talking prehistory and
you're talking about a much smaller
scale how do you keep that scale feeling
small because you're not going to
explore the world because it's
prehistory so it'd be interesting to see
how you treat those units so they still
feel like it's part of the tribe it's
important to keep them alive I'm alone
in that aspect maybe maybe the excom
approach feels a little bit more
interesting where when they do die it
means a lot more because they're not out
farming and getting food wastage so you
say that I think that civ operates on
bizarre abstractions the fact that your
leader like George Washington lives for
a thousand years it's a little weird
right or that a unit is the size of a
mountain on the map we sort of deal in
abstraction whenever and I think to make
that mechanic work we would have to
introduce a new one which is to say
these military units have names and they
live you know for a while unless the
time scale were to adjust to accommodate
you know I like that they live for a
while I'm I mean intrigued by the
suggestion of like these legendary
characters and in my mind like you could
take that you could take all these and
wrap them up into a mode where your
military units are like a hero character
with his warband and like it's very
important who that guy is cuz that
governs like how his army his little
warband fights and they've got to go out
and prove themselves to get better like
it's mostly a sort of an experiential
progress and less about technology and
then if he gets killed maybe we can like
save the player at that point to say
he's not kill but wounded comes back to
the camp and now he's like you know
crusty old guy in the camp telling the
young warriors how to fight and so you
could he's still alive you don't have to
like go through the emotional heart ache
there was risk in the fact that now you
lost him on the battlefield but he can
still contribute to your sieve and
you were sort of reinforcing this idea
that the tribe is a group of individuals
that are alive and that have the story
together what about them that's a that's
a really interesting approach it's um my
gut is that that would take it really a
really interesting and unique design
approach to make that balance out with a
scope of time and if you're passing time
would that still work what it would pull
you out of the game a little bit too
much to have you that attached to have
how to stuff continue like that I guess
it's a tricky question yeah if every
turn is a year then it becomes plausible
but then you know you can't I mean 300
years i guess the enough enough time
would have passed to get to hit those
historical markers in to meet the
fantasy there right i mean other games
have solved this in interesting ways if
you think about what's the double fine
mess of tow massive chalice thank you if
you think about massive chalice like
those heroes you know they retire and
then they have kids and there's rogue
legacy too i don't know if any of you
guys played that same same deal so
there's some interesting ways to work
around that but i think in giving these
units on the map personality an
attachment is a powerful force and
really sort of Remus eyeses the things
we move on to emphasize here I also like
to point out that what you're witnessing
is actually a very common move for Sid
designers and it was an all 4 x's
designer thing to Jake mentioned the
same thing we have a system that we like
the sound of we have a gameplay that we
like the sound of we want to say this is
gonna be fun for players to use and now
we're trying to find a way to to fit the
fiction of the game to it so the
gameplay came first and now we're trying
to make it work with the story and
that's how we tend to approach these
games like we're very much about game
play folk first at four accents it's
very much why I think civ games are the
way they are and why it's such a
venerable and successful franchise we
think about what you do not what we're
telling you it means but I mean we can't
do without both but it is in this order
so i think it's certainly it yeah most
of the time it's like it's gameplay but
that is also influenced by the fantasy i
think yeah we want to put the player in
a role and have them do interesting
things and mechanics come from fantasy
but they're also you know it works the
other way too it doesn't have to be
locked like that we often have designs
especially if you're talking down a path
like that where you have somebody who
stays alive well
often have that tried out in game at
people playing it because until we play
it we're not sure if it's gonna be fun
so stuff doesn't have to just exist at a
written design document layer and then
it's going in and that's that right all
right I like the sound of this i think
that's that's gonna serve the role in
this sieve game that it does in other
sift games okay Thank You Dennis Exodus
moving on alright so we've done
exploration we've done growth now we've
done combat I think the next step is
about the face about it's about the
future what is the backbone of
progression the main way that we gauge
our our distance from the end you know
how we how we negotiate the game and
like yeah what you would what is the
most long-term of the long term which
would have to be technology and culture
so every civ game has had some kind of
tech progression starting from civil one
we had sort of a you know a tech tree it
was always a tree until beyond Earth
when it was a web but you made these
decisions he's sort of high-level
long-term decisions long-term
investments that guided your
civilization guided your culture through
the game and it's a great barometer for
how well you're doing where I am what
air I am I mean it's all so long what
some of the most fun parts of the myth
like it's romantic to look down the tech
tree and see gunpowder or see metallurgy
or see rocketry it's romantic to look at
the civics and see you know like
fundamentalism or like communism you
like oh who would be like to play is
that because we know what those mean but
we also know that they're big grand idea
so it's fun to work towards them and
then like take on the mantle and live it
for a while so they're very evocative
they're one of the most resonant parts
of the game the scientific and cultural
ideas so this is where like the game
gets really philosophical and it's also
why almost always these have been really
heavily abstracted like a lot of menus
it's not it doesn't exist on the map the
way you know mammoths and fire and
warriors can the same way it's really
got exists in the mind of the player so
it's a very tricky system or subset of
the game to design but all the more
important to get right and in order to
do that we're going to ask Anton
stringer designer extraordinaire on
civilization five expansions and beyond
Earth to join us
so Anton you designed world congress and
league system intensify force if an you
designed the virtues in beyond Earth
mm-hmm so when we say technology culture
in progress in prehistory what do you
think about yeah technology and culture
and prehistory we're kind of like you
can see it sorry insane person then
we'll get the prehistory sir yes I guess
more generally to meet you guys have
talked a lot about myth and I totally
agree I think technology and culture are
kind of like the most closely linked to
pillar to the myth of the game and civ
as always this really nice balance of
there are parts that are procedural and
random and different every time and then
the player tells their own story and
there are other parts where there's
similar things every time and you can
kind of rely on a sort of common thread
underneath all of your playthroughs and
I think technology and culture are that
second thing so the technology and the
culture are traditionally the least on
the map of all the pillars but they also
set the the rules for the game in a way
in a way that's pretty fundamental level
and far-reaching and they kind of in my
mind the definition is kind of like they
define what is possible and when it is
possible so thinking about culture and
technology in in prehistory what are
some of the things that we would need to
learn how would we learn feet eight go
Pete Pete run faster back then they
thought um they like they needed to
sacrifice goats or do a dance to like
get it dying or give victory in battle
or essentially how it worked like you
needed to sacrifice 2x god yeah religion
superstition these things bill play much
bigger role uh customs depending on how
the culture grows okay uh timekeeping
how interesting how do you measure time
and sorry that could lead into a thought
of what if as the game progressed the
length of time that a turn encompassed
changed yeah are just kind of does that
I mean that there's time dilation yeah a
quick aside in civ already but that
driving it by discovery of
clocks is pretty cool yeah like that
handicaps cuz if you develop the spear
you're gonna be less likely to develop
like the bow c1 technology makes of
other technologies harvest this makes
the suit again yeah taking on some style
like we're the where the horse Bowman or
where the dispute Minh I feel like in
prehistory there would be no like
language or communication would come
connotation language is huge white
William yep even before agriculture that
was one of the foundational things that
makes us human uh in the specific
cultures may be this your tribe deals
with warriors better so the words
improve or maybe they deal with bison
more and so they worship the Bison and
bison give them more food or they deal
with gatherers more so the gatherers are
able to produce more food and whatever
your tribe happens to worship or looks
up to so specialization is I think I
think that's good one of the one of the
great things that the technology
progression does in a sieve game is
unlock new possibilities it's like an
ever-increasing possibility space yep so
with some of these suggestions like
timekeeping I think I think time key
things are really goes in but I like the
religion and religion ritual what
pushing back the darkness pushing by the
darkness I wrote what are the mechanical
things that these technologies unlock so
when i get when i learned how to how to
tell time or how the Sun moves or
calendar or whatever what what does that
let me do in the game right so I think
timekeeping for example could let you I
guess be more measured and more
methodical about moving around the map
you could maybe plan your people to say
okay go out here and hunt these mammoth
would come back will probably lead to
the earliest beginnings of Agriculture
you can understand how long crops need
to the serum and stuff like and I think
the the whole sort of like wild areas
untamed areas versus tamed areas is
something that you could kind of slowly
do with whatever technology is in the
prehistory game and so like you kind of
learn okay well these are kind of the
dangers of a DES of this desert region
and I understand them now I've hunted
animals here there's this sort of tribal
knowledge that's passed down this
culture this identity that we've built
and that allows me mechanically as a
player with my group my tribe to sort of
tame this land and make it my own so
this taming thing we've got in terms of
growth technology is enabling
that but it's it's it's a cycle so so
the growth the more time you spend in a
region the more you can research it so
to speak yeah the more your research it
the better you are there so yeah it's
reinforcing yeah so there could be a
tribe and maybe this is sort of a wide
versus tall play style thing where you
have a tribe and you stay in the desert
the whole game and you really milk those
bonuses and get become experts at that
and maybe that's how you win or you kind
of are a roving band you track different
migratory patterns of animals which i
think is also a really cool mechanic
across different biomes and you kind of
get a little bit of everything and we're
have a more diverse tech path I think
definitely technology someone admission
idea earlier about the migratory
patterns being able to predict those i
think is really cool because maybe you
start out the beginning of the game and
like okay they moved three tiles but
they went to the darkness do I follow
them is it dangerous there but then
eventually you've hunted them enough or
you have enough technology that you're
like okay well I know that they're going
here I can see that even though I
haven't explored that area that yet or
even though I haven't explored it in a
while I kind of know that about the map
even though I can't see it right now I
really like the idea of language gating
lots of different things yeah certainly
interactions with other players right
maybe but the first time you meet
another player in the game and you
haven't research language all you can do
is kill them but oh well you you know
after after you've learned it to spin
you learn how to kill them a different
way right communicates different things
but that has the seeds of some sort of
diplomatic interaction or economic
interaction yeah also governments so
yeah you know thinking about World
Congress which you design language
gating some sort of some sort of
government that you can impose on your
own civilization is an interesting idea
too but I think so it comes up if King
right yeah yeah exactly and I think one
of the big parts that at the beginning
of a traditional sieve game is kind of
ticket for credits yeah you have this
government you have this organization
that's already set up you have this
cultural identity in prehistory civ I
think it's fun to not have that yet and
language could be a big part of that to
leading your government I think an
additional language and agriculture
another big pillar for me for you know
prehistorical humans becoming
civilizations was kind of
diversification of labor and that's
really what agricultural out so like you
know when when we're a tribe we all have
to go hunt and gather in our own ways
maybe we have roles or specialties but
once we sort of settle down and figure
out okay well like you can write stuff
down and you know devote your life to
that because it's really hard and we
don't have a fax machine or copy machine
and you know you can go hunt because
you're really good at that and you can
make the advanced weapons for hunting
because that's really hard you can't
just pick up a stick now we know what
swords are that sort of thing it also
works really well talking to Dennis
earlier works really well with these the
idea that your units are more personal
yeah they're more specialized so it's
like how you are a blacksmith right you
have specialized cities in civilization
now perhaps you have specialized units
in banning them together it writes the
tribe right and that identity could be
linked to them or their family you know
for multiple terms across generations
looking it's a civics screenshot I'm now
imagining like the first one is guy who
is biggest guys man Hardesty man history
biggest and smartest guy together that's
our progress so um what about what about
the UM where we were talking a little
bit about the animals and like the
things that you fight and how like the
world is full of danger is that you
eventually make into resources yeah we
have to talk a lot about resources but I
think we were sort of assuming that
they're things like animals and plants
that you domesticate or learn how to
grow right so but what's what's got like
technologies usually what governs that
like if I can't kill a mammoth now how
do I learn how to do that right yeah so
I mentioned earlier that technology is
kind of like off the map in a way that
the other pose aren't but but there's
definitely overlapped like you guys say
like we try to overlap our systems and
that leads to a lot of rich interactions
so you know in a traditional sip game
you have technology sort of reveals
resources or allows them to you allows
you to use them in a way that you hadn't
before and I think that would work here
as well like there are things out on the
map there are mammoths you don't you
know you start out the game and your
people don't know like is this is this
do they eat grass do they eat people
like dude are they gonna hurt me are
they just very docile I think that
Dave's Dave's sort of getting at the
implement too yeah yeah how do we cool
make tool-making is like right huge part
of prehistory civilization and yeah
perhaps the entire that could be that's
basically like the it's like the
agriculture of this game right first
yeah I can make a cool and then so what
do I make it out of what is it for how
specialized is it how sophisticated is
yeah someone had mentioned stone clubs
in the one of the first idea gathering
session
and yeah when I first heard the theme a
very short time ago when I was thinking
of technology yeah the first thing that
came to mind was tools because that was
really I there weren't as you haven't
civ traditional sale on turn one you
don't you don't have like a group of
scientists producing beakers in a lab in
prehistory you don't really in actual
history either but it's an abstraction
but you know like that's what size works
yeah what is what is science in
prehistory it's it's practical use of
things immediately in front of you like
there wasn't this long view there were
these mythologies that are these
religions but it was about what is the
tool I can use and that was another
pillar of what makes civilization
civilization as they also have a neat
opportunity there to overlap what you're
finding on the map with what's happening
in the tech trees totally yeah you find
you know that stone that you can nap
into an axe yeah that bet sure that's
your research that's your progress yeah
you don't kind of like conceptualize and
write acts in the abstract you see
something there and you're like what if
that and that were together so one of de
minecraft level at one of David's
favorite games in the entire world is
colonization yes David loves
colonization the original like not not
the sip for version but still play the
original colonization is one of days
favorite games in that game the unit
that you had was entirely about the tool
that they possessed and the cool
military the military Ryan the tool is a
thing that you made from simpler parts
which I always thought was a very
elegant solution and you could give
several tools to a unit and as they you
know took damage or whatever they would
lose them gradually becoming less and
less effective yeah so that that circle
is really neat find something on the map
improve it into tool using research
science put it on a guy make the guy
better repeat it operates more like a
holistic glove like this is my tribe
warm again it's might have tribe or van
plus stone so my tribal war n plus boat
stone in BOS yeah like those are like
right tears of power yeah it would be
commensurate of roughly to like spearmen
swordsman Knights tanks at the same time
though like I really likes that mechanic
to I haven't played colonization as much
as you have but it'll talk it is
impossible but at the same time we've
talked earlier about having this sort of
like time of heroes and legends and if
we're not careful you know if if
it's in prehistory Donna Sedaka becomes
a story of like okay well I have people
and I give them tools it might become
about the tools and where they are as
opposed to the people so it'll be an
interesting balancing fine there were
things that you characterize tech
progression or military progression is
like in this equipment terms yes like I
am I warriors who know how to warrior
but this time they're armed with bones
and this time they're armed with with
you know I earn tips beers and that's
right that's the difference for VA whoa
so one of Anton's favorite games is
final fantasy tactics this is on loves
tactics and the character progression
and tactics is entirely about equipment
well not entirely but it's like you've
got your guy who has persistence and
personality but does the equipment you
put on the guy that really and the job
that they end a job it's a sort of put a
role for them and they definitely you
know some are suited for one better than
another and right so i think there's
there are ways that you can reconcile
and ex-con business very well to
reconcile the the investment you put
into equipment and the investment you
put into the people which are which
unfortunately you know habit rishon
sometimes they die yeah and finding that
balance is very important but also i
mean in CF though we can use this to get
all of the things you do so like
equipment could also be how well you can
erect a camp yeah what you can do with
the land at is on or how how tame you
can really make this place yeah what you
can do in this in this region that you'd
grow your tribe is growing up and that
you understand really well like find
that desert tribe I know where to find
water at the store of the game I can
only find it in oasis which maybe I know
exactly where they all are but later on
if I got better tools I also know how to
dig for it yeah and I know I have the
capability to dig for it so I'm even
better eventually you get to the point
where you can set up that city and we've
now arrived at regular Susie and God
help the person that tries to invade you
in the desert because that is your land
right that's the holy superstition that
your frites and jinns will come brighten
their souls yeah so that I think that's
a good sort of survey of progression
here thank you and thanks I've done for
help thank you
all right okay so in conclusion coming
down so at this point this would have
been like I don't know an afternoon's
worth of work to just throw ideas around
like this and there's a lot more of
these that will now occur if we were if
this was a real game that we're really
making or what we're talking about how
beyond earth was made this continues
many many many many times over where we
think very very deeply and critically
but also at very high level very sort of
philosophically about every move that's
going to be made in the game and what it
really means not just what the player is
going to do but how it expresses civ as
opposed to another game how it's going
to work with all the other systems what
synergies are going to be there what is
going to be lost if we're abandoning
I'll tried-and-true mechanics from a
passive games like if we take on this
war bands idea and now we don't have
armies anymore how does that change the
way military feels is it is it more fun
to have the old way or the new way civ
is a game that exists on a continuum
they're never just made in isolation but
this is a little bit of of the thought
of the thought process of like what it's
what it feels like to sit down and
contemplate how do you make a game of a
new game of civ game that belongs to the
civ franchise but is at the same time
yet so how did we do let's let's bring
up an expert to a pass judgment on this
whole exercise Sid Meier
so Sid you have some experience with
civilization working on a prototype over
there so is it already done now this is
really this is really fun a really cool
Oh a couple things come to my mind
actually as I'm listening I'm designing
a prototype I my mind it's kind of like
what are the tricky things that we would
deal with first you know I think when
we're prototyping a lot of stuff we know
we can do and that but there's always
some new things that were kind of unsure
of that we kind of go to first and
that's kind of what went through my mind
listening to these ideas one of the
things that I think we try to do is to
put you in the coolest role in this
world like who's having the most fun in
this in this world I think that's a
question that comes up here you know in
pirates you're the captain of the pirate
ship that's the coolest person in that
world you know in civ you get to manage
the civilization you get to make all
these decisions here it's a little it's
not quite as clear to me who's having
the fun you know is it that conan person
you know in that unit that's really
having the fun I think you we need we
would need to work to make the role that
you have this kind of overlord of this
world where the cool funds what happens
I think that would be one challenge I
think in putting a prototype like this
together another kind of pillar of civ
in my mind is this idea of multiple kind
of simple accessible systems working
together to create an interesting
complexity and the interaction between
systems and that kind of is borne out in
civ when you've got one guy over here
exploring you've got something about to
be built over here you've got a
technology being researched and your
kind of constantly kind of going around
checking on how all these things are
doing and it's not that important where
you are you don't feel like you're at a
place on the map you know this world
feels like I I might be a little more
interested in kind of being down there
on the ground you know doing things and
that that leads to kind of another
question
choosing the system first or the topic
that's an interesting question you know
you've kind of said we're going to use a
civic approach to this world that's one
way of approaching it ah but I might
think of okay i want to bring prehistory
to life with no preconceptions you know
what game would i make in that case you
know what it would it be for x or would
it be would it take a different approach
and i think that's a that's kind of a
you know going back thinking about how
we approach pirates and games like that
was kind of like here's the topic here
the cool things we want to happen let's
find some systems whether they're from
RPG or action or whatever to kind of
bring that to life and i think there's
an opportunity here to maybe break out
of the mold a little bit and think think
about how combat might work differently
from sieve or you know or whatever and
the other the other question that comes
to mind here is a problem we had with
the original sieve and continue to have
through all the sibs what where do you
stop how do you how do you how do you
manage the complexity of the game a
sieve is such a rich topic that we can
easily overwhelm the player and you've
got kind of a lot of stuff going on here
and how do i as the player kind of keep
a thread of a story in my mind that ties
all this all these things together i
think that's that's kind of a challenge
with all the different parts happening
there's a there's a simplicity and sieve
that all my all my legions are the same
so I have a legion model I can I know
what legions do if every unit is kind of
different than you know was that the guy
that was good at bison writing or was
that the cow riding guy who's that guy
you know as you cycle around the world
trying to keep all that stuff in your
mind I think that would be kind of an
interesting challenge so sieve manages
to
create almost an illusion of complexity
by putting these simple systems together
and what's powerful about that is that
the player owns those systems
understands them and can project them
into the future and the more that your
player is kind of playing the next turn
in the turn after that as opposed to the
turn that they're currently on the more
that becomes very rich in their mind and
I think that there are some very good
examples of how that how you could
create that here with the kind of
projecting the migration of the herds
and things like that i think but finding
finding ways for the player to kind of
be thinking in the future is a really
powerful i think part of the the sieve
experience but there's some you know
some some really cool ideas i think
what's it saying is that our game is
terrible we're gonna blame you guys that
was never designed by committee you
should never object lesson no I know I
think it's I think it's a really cool
idea again it's kind of like a lot of
stuff we know how to do I'm kind of you
know but my mind goes to all right what
are the problems we'd have to solve to
kind of make this all come together and
those are the you know those are the
things that that strike me going back to
sorry we did not define the exes before
we originally designed see if they kind
of came out of the came out of the
process of again looking at the topic
and saying well okay here's a here's a
children's book you know what are the
what are the things we know about the
history civilization how do we bring
them to life and how do we make these
kind of simple systems work together
which is really a lesson we learn from
from railroad tycoon how how managing
the rail running the railroad operating
the trains buying and selling stock oh
you know that stuff kind of individually
was manageable but it just things
interacted in a very fascinating way
that made every game different and kind
of stiff had that same quality with the
map and things like that I was a little
concerned not to be I know I'm very
picky I'm sorry a little concerned with
the idea of the map changing when you
weren't looking at
uh-uh players are spooky and sensitive
and we think about a scalability like
starting small and working your way to a
larger map I think it's a bad idea it's
it's hard enough to make one good game
and you're really making two or three
good games at that point so so good luck
with that all right oh it's funny you
you're talking about like the Civic
approach which I must be amusing to you
of all people to hero like people like
us coming in 30 years later and saying
there's approach now that you invented
whether you meant to or not versus like
thinking about the the premise of the
game is saying what is the game that
makes that and is beyond Earth is a
really good example like we we designed
a game that was that had both of those
questions before it and we definitely
picked deliberately so the Civic
approach because we wanted the game to
belong to the sieve to the core
civilization franchise and so we said
here's our premise it's the future so
it's human settling another planet
what's the Civic approach answer that I
sitting here now when you're saying that
thinking like if we were just to take
that topic alone human settling another
planet with no preconceptions what kind
of game that would have been or could be
would be is a very very new thought
bubble for me on the other hand there's
a lot of actually advantages of using
the civ model sit in the same way that
back in the RTS day you know we had we
knew the conventions we knew what
right-click did with left click did we
kind of knew how things were going to
work in the same way the Sailor time
what is what's that happier simpler yes
or two buttons and that was right in the
same way that you come to a topic with
uh you know your your preconceptions of
what's cool about pirates or history or
dinosaurs or railroads whatever I think
you come to a sieve game with a lot of
knowledge about how it works you know we
you can you you understand kind of
what's going to be important that's
going to grow that things are going to
you know you kind of know how to play
before you start which is an advantage
using the missive model I think yeah
it's interesting like when you when you
made the original sieve
the genres were not as clearly defined
in games and now i think it's fallen
into genres like movies have you make a
comedy you make an action movie etc etc
and there's deviation from those things
but there are these conventions people
understand and expect that you have to
meet yeah I think as a sib designers
particularly now as we approach civ
figuring out which one's of which
conventions we wanted to meet
expectation with which ones we wanted to
throw out what we needed to change how
conservative we should be to the civ 5
model versus changing the formula has
ramifications like you know I wish we
could design a game like that like let's
just in a vacuum design game about space
and all that but there are things like
tech considerations and expectation and
marketing promotion it's like there's
all this stuff now somehow said you have
managed to avoid all that stuff in your
career how do you how do you like you
know what's the black magic there that
you get to make games in that in that
headspace where you're not thinking
about genre you're not thinking about
mechanics it's just what the players
going to do and how they're going to do
it well that's really where we started i
think you know and when you look back at
the history of Firaxis and before that
Microprose you know our games we're kind
of all over the map in terms of flight
simulators and pirates and railroads and
civilization and covert action I'm
actually plugging a session will be
doing later today where we talk about
all those games um but but it was kind
of this topic first approach i think
it's like all right here's the pirates
you know okay what's cool about pirates
there's got to be some sword-fighting
there's got to be ship battles there's
got to be this finding treasure you know
I mean not trying to make that fit we
didn't have John Rose back in those days
you know I think that was a somewhat of
a liberating thing we didn't have to
conform to a genre convention so we
could kind of make these games and you
know honestly the the the bar in terms
of graphics and things like that wasn't
as high so we could focus a lot of our
energy on the gameplay and iterate and
kind of you know once we had a game that
worked we slap a little bit of graphic
and ship it out there and people would
add their imagination and it would be it
would be cool you know so mmm and i
think the stakes weren't as high you
know honestly as they are today with
with the budgets in the cost of games so
again talking later on today about the
good old days of game design but it you
know it's there's still you know thank
we're in a world actually with india et
cetera where there's still those kind of
opportunities but they're they're you
know they're kind of done it and a
different scale all right so one more
question with our our seconds remaining
based on what you've seen today would
you green light this project to go
forward and develop priest Donna safe
Doc's abducts based on the title loan
yes well that is ninety percent of game
design is naming stuff all right thank
you so much thanks admire everybody
and thank all of you for participating
here in this this experiment hopefully
we'll get to do this again Dave thank
you thank you thank you thank you guys
for coming for ex-con this is awesome
and we'll see you next year